Buongiorno grazie a tutti grazie degli
applausi ma non ho ancora detto niente
quindi vediamo dopo come va
te di X sempre visto sempre sentito di
solito Vengono persone a parlare che
hanno una brillante carriera che hanno
fatto cose importanti con un bel
curriculum
persone serie cioè non io Ok quindi
quando Damiano mi ha detto Vieni a
parlare al nostro Ted X ho detto io che
gli racconto sul fare la differenza
riflettendo così mi viene da dire che
noi la differenza la facciamo in vari
modi
ma Uno principale è proprio l'esserci Ok
è la nostra identità e come ci definiamo
E allora sono partito un po' della mia
esperienza che magari non è
rappresentativo di tutto ma è quello che
io da portare a voi oggi
fare la differenza con la propria
identità Cosa vuol dire la nostra
identità la definiamo in tanti modi
probabilmente
ma soprattutto
c'è un modo di definirla che a volte la
propria professione Ok Io mi sono
chiesto come mi definisco io avete
sentito che nel piccolo curriculum che
mi avete chiesto ho fatto mettere varie
cose però io principalmente quando mi
chiedono cosa faccio dico che sono un
attore
Cosa vuol dire essere attori
essere attori pensate alla parola no
anche in inglese Act
significa semplicemente agire fare delle
cose Ok non è soltanto recitare
all'inizio e allora volevo partire da
qui con voi oggi un po' in questo
viaggio sul fare la differenza
attraverso l'esserci e la propria
presenza
L'attore è qualcuno che agisce che fa
delle sentiamo anche tutti i giorni no
un attore economico un attore politico
non necessariamente un attore teatrale o
cinematografico
E allora partiamo da qua questa era la
mia definizione personale ma ce ne sono
altre più qualificate della mia ad
esempio Shakespeare ok Il principe del
teatro occidentale quello che secondo me
ha fatto un po' la somma di tutto diceva
che tutto il mondo è un palcoscenico no
l'attore in grado di agire tutto il
mondo di raccontare attraverso la sua
presenza facendo finta di essere qualcun
altro tutte le sfumature dell'umanità e
del mondo intero e questa è la prima
definizione vedete come
il Teatro la vita per Shakespeare non
erano poi così diversi ok uno doveva
rappresentare l'altra ci deve dare uno
specchio e c'è un'altra definizione che
è molto più recente conoscete Peter
Brook
non siete timidi potete dire anche di no
Allora è uno dei più importanti registra
teatrale del Novecento che definiva il
teatro come secondo voi
Cioè cos'è il teatro
cosa come lo definireste voi
ok no troppo filosofico Peter Brook
diceva che il teatro è
una persona che fa qualcosa e un'altra
persona che la guarda
semplice No in questo senso Tutti
possiamo essere attori ok Oggi ci sono
io sul palco ci siete voi che mi
Guardate Ma pensate uno al bar che
prende un caffè ed è visto da qualcun
altro secondo la definizione di Peter
Brooks pure quello è un attore ok
portiamo a spasso il cane facciamo un
giro
cuciniamo a casa No tutti siamo attori
per qualcun altro anche qui il teatro e
la vita si incontrano Ok allora mi sono
detto forse se queste due persone molto
più importanti di me la pensavano così
questo teatro può essere veramente
qualcosa che fa la differenza può dire
qualcosa alle persone e ho trovato sei
parole che hanno a che fare con il mio
lavoro col teatro da cui trarre delle
metafore e delle competenze per la vita
La prima è palco palcoscenico questo ok
il teatro quello convenzionale normale
si fa sul palcoscenico Questo è un parco
un luogo rialzato che ha tendenzialmente
buio Ok pericoloso perché ci sono cose
appese cose per terra scenografie in cui
è meglio non inciampare o che non ti
cadano addosso
è un luogo che bisogna conoscere che ha
una sua geografia che ha una sua
gerarchia in cui ogni cosa non è lì per
caso
e questa è la prima metafora che trovo
cioè il nostro contesto contesto che
ognuno di noi vive tutti i giorni che
può essere per voi la scuola la vostra
città al vostro paese la nostra nazione
Insomma ci sono contesti più o meno
grandi concentrici dentro i quali
viviamo
Cosa bisogna fare per non farsi male su
un palco tendenzialmente conoscerlo
conoscerne la geografia riuscire andare
da una parte all'altra sapendo cosa c'è
per terra dove meglio che non passo e
così il nostro contesto quindi la prima
competenza che volevo lasciarvi oggi è
questa
conosciate tutto non tralasciate niente
cercate di conoscere davvero tutto di
leggere tutto quanto sarebbe noiosa la
vita Se a un certo punto noi non
avessimo più niente da conoscere di
nuovo ok Oggi siete a scuola Magari non
la vedete proprio così ma vi assicuro
che il poter conoscere cose nuove è
qualcosa che ci può nutrire
continuamente
seconda parola che è sempre una parola
un po' collettiva compagnia
Che cos'è una compagnia teatrale intendo
gruppo di attori Ok cosa fanno
recitano e quindi fanno funzionare uno
uno spettacolo ok
la compagnia Cos'è che può essere di
cosa può essere la metafora del nostro
prossimo le persone che abbiamo intorno
una compagnia te la scegli no
tendenzialmente la sceglie un produttore
o un regista Quindi tu ti trovi in un
gruppo di persone
alcune con le quali trovi benissimo
altre che non sopporti altre che non
sopportano te però ci devi convivere
perché lo spettacolo è la cosa più
importante
è l'obiettivo che tutti Avete Ok pensate
nella vita noi scegliamo una famiglia
scegliamo un vicino di casa scegliamo un
collega no tendenzialmente a volte non
scegliamo neanche gli amici ce li
troviamo Ok sugli amici c'è un po' più
di libertà però tendenzialmente le
persone che abbiamo intorno non ce le
siamo scelte a volte ce le troviamo e
tutti abbiamo in comune due cose
Secondo voi
cos'è che possiamo avere in comune con
gli altri
una cosa che abbiamo tutti ve lo
assicuro anche se qualcuno non lo
ammette
come
no
tutti hanno un lato positivo uno
negativo Ok dei pregi e dei difetti
sbaglio Voi siete senza difetti
Ovvio Bravissimo No tutti abbiamo
qualcosa che non va è qualcosa che
invece è più funzionale Ok io trovo che
oggi il fare la differenza a volte è
difficile perché la nostra società in
generale da un lato ci dice che non
abbiamo difetti Ok si dice che dobbiamo
essere perfetti dall'altro invece c'è li
sottolinea perché il difetto Cosa fa fa
sì che noi abbiamo bisogno di comprare
dei prodotti Ok ci crea dei bisogni Che
poi automaticamente magicamente ci
soddisfa pensate prodotti di bellezza
Oppure quelle cose se siete mai stati
non so in Grandi Magazzini dove ci sono
delle cose Assolutamente inutili che
però vi vien da comprare di cui non
sapevate di aver bisogno ok Quella è la
mancanza che ci viene generata dalla
nostra società
fare la differenza secondo me sta in
questo vedere i propri Talenti o vedere
i talenti di chi ci sta intorno Ok avere
la consapevolezza che tutti abbiamo
qualcosa di buono e dobbiamo trovare il
modo di sottolinearlo negli altri di
farlo risplendere e negli altri in noi
stessi e soprattutto in noi stessi
trovare i talenti a volte non è facile
perché ci scoraggiamo
ad esempio prima il presentatore diceva
che i più timidi di voi oggi parleranno
Ok gli attori sono tutti similissimi non
è necessariamente un difetto è un pregio
Ok soprattutto per stare in scena ve lo
dice uno che è una pre folle degli altri
cioè sono timidissimo
la terza parola abbiamo detto
palcoscenico compagnia
poi un'altra cosa collettiva che c'è
nel teatro
guardatevi intorno voi siete un pubblico
Ok il pubblico Di cosa è fatto è questa
entità che l'attore si trova davanti
quando sta sul palco è un po' questo
corpo unico però il fatto di tante
persone o sbaglio ognuna con la sua
sensibilità però che insieme quando
compongono un pubblico hanno una certa
temperatura hanno un umore no e l'attore
questa cosa la sente capisce se un
pubblico è più attento se ha voglia di
ridere se non ha voglia di ridere se
deve tirarlo un po' di più
per me l'immagine un po' della nostra
società no tante volte diciamo società
l'ho detto anch'io prima ma non sappiamo
bene che cos'è la società la società
siamo tutti noi insieme delle persone
delle istituzioni tutto quello che
compone il nostro essere degli animali
sociali
sapete che l'uomo non può vivere senza
gli altri Ok togliamoci dal discorso che
siamo individualisti perché non funziona
questa società Appunto Noi possiamo
ascoltarla possiamo sapere l'umore che
ha e quello che ci può trasmettere ma
conoscendola e sentendo quello che ci
restituisce possiamo dire la nostra che
può essere
concordare se le cose ci piacciono e può
essere dissentire se le cose invece non
ci piacciono e in quello sta fare la
differenza soprattutto se non la
pensiamo in termini di grandi cose di
grandi avvenimenti di grandi gesta a
volte bastano i gesti veramente piccoli
per fare la differenza nella nostra
società queste tre parole collettive
Adesso ve le voglio dire tre invece che
sono totalmente individuali La prima è
corpo gli attori hanno un corpo
Sì ok Cosa fa un corpo ci mette in
relazione con gli altri fisicamente Ok
noi siamo un po' il nostro corpo è
quello che ci tiene in vita fisicamente
e questo corpo pone dei limiti però può
abbracciare può allontanare e deve
essere un corpo per gli attori allenato
perché il teatro è fatica Ok sono corse
salti bisogna spesso urlare e portare la
voce Non come oggi che per fortuna
Damiano mi ha dato un microfono e quindi
arrivo più facilmente avere un corpo
allenato
non soltanto nel senso fisico ma essere
allenati ai continui cambiamenti che la
vita ci pone davanti significa sapersi
adattare perché la vita cambia anche se
noi non lo vogliamo ma essere pronti a
saper cogliere le opportunità e sapere
mettere la nostra differenza dentro
quelle opportunità
collegate al corpo c'è un'altra parola
che è Voce La Voce Di solito noi la
pensiamo come qualcosa di incorpore o
qualcosa di arioso Ok ma la voce
dell'attore ha due caratteristiche uno
che viene da dove
Vediamo se lo sapete
bravissimo Avete studiato Eh avete
vicino arriva dal diaframma alla voce
dell'attore è un muscolo che sta qui
sotto i polmoni tra i polmoni lo stomaco
Ok nessuno sa bene dove sia sta lì
piatto questa voce
arriva da dentro arriva dal nostro
intimo tutto quello che noi dobbiamo
dire per fare la differenza devono
essere le cose importanti per noi non
dobbiamo solo ripetere quello che dicono
gli altri Dobbiamo capire cos'è
importante per me cos'è che io voglio
dire al mio mondo e con cosa voglio fare
la differenza oggi quindi qualcosa che
viene da dentro e poi una voce
amplificata che si amplifica o perché
l'attore a tecnica è bravo a portarla in
fondo dove c'è la vecchietta che ha
pagato 20 euro di biglietto e non vuoi
che te li chieda indietro Vuole che tu
vuoi che lei senta
ma
anche una voce che può essere
amplificata da un microfono la
responsabilità di amplificare la vostra
voce ragazzi è tutta vostra non c'è
nessuno che lo farà per voi c'è chi
cerca di non farvelamplificare di non
farla arrivare dove vuole se è scomoda
Ma la prima responsabilità di dire
quello che voi volete è assolutamente
vostra
tutte queste parole io riassumo con
l'ultima che rischio di essere fuori
tempo poi
attraverso cosa viene visto un attore
gli occhi la performance no c'è una cosa
molto più easy teatro è buio No Cosa
serve per vedere un attore le luci la
luce per un attore Quando si comincia a
recitare la cosa più difficile da
prendere perché la luce va presa che
devo stare in una posizione in cui la
luce mi arriva in faccia e mi si vede in
volto sempre perché la vecchietta
altrimenti chiede indietro i €20 di
biglietto
questa luce è una luce di riflesso
nessuno di noi Brilla di luce propria
brigliamo nella misura in cui noi Ci
affidiamo un pubblico
che ci viene a vederci in ragione sua
Noi esistiamo
brilliamo nella misura in cui gli altri
ci lasciano spazio per dire le nostre
battute la nostra compagnia ci aiuta e
nella misura in cui noi diamo a loro
spazio per dire le loro E se qualcuno si
dimentica una battuta interveniamo noi
oppure intervengono loro quando ci
incartiamo succede spessissimo
ragazzi Il mio augurio oggi è che questa
luce Riuscite a essere voi non è una
metafora
è quello che secondo me fa la differenza
nei piccoli gesti come nei grandi nelle
scelte grosse come in quelle piccole Il
segreto è essere una luce per gli altri
e questo lo augurio che vi faccio oggi
Grazie mille
[Applauso]